the jurogan experience the taliban have
taken over afghanistan that's a creepy
one it looks weird um
you see the people falling from the
plane i did that's wild
it's it's weird it's rushing the plane
trying to get on board and trying to get
rescued and taken out of the country
[ __ ] it it's so odd you know i was
having a conversation with um with
friends just just yesterday and i was
saying i literally had forgotten like i
was like why why was the us in
afghanistan again it had been so long
i was literally trying to remember what
the initial reason
for going in there was yeah but i mean
i'm no foreign policy expert i'm not
going to pretend to be but it seems very
obvious that the way they withdrew
was
crazy and leaving all the leaving all
their weapons and ammunition and
vehicles and stuff like that for the
taliban to just come and scoop up if one
was a legit conspiracy theorist
like a real tin foil hatter you would
look at this and go this is probably the
best way to ensure
the support of a re-invasion
like leave a bunch of weapons behind
make the whole thing disastrous have the
taliban take over the entire country in
a short period of time start executing
women mayors do all the crazy [ __ ]
they're probably gonna do
and then you know have some
real public outcry
so weird people are con i still get
people who are confused as to why i do
not generally trust the government and i
don't know how many examples i need to
pull out from recent times and from
further history to just be like look
whether whether this is malice or its
incompetence or
um
with some things it doesn't matter all
right whether it's malice or incompetent
incompetence in anything but but how can
with certain things i'm like how how can
it be like it's so
obvious right it's so obvious what is
going to happen in a certain situation
and then you'd
do it anyway
and
i i don't i don't understand that one
person can be incompetent but it's like
it's not just one person
who makes all these ideas they've got
actual people who are supposed to be
experts and advisors etc i mean you even
had people in the media last last month
and the media is pretty friendly towards
joe biden here for the most part and
people in the media are saying hey if
you do this aren't the taliban gonna
just
take over everything he's like no and
he's like no no there's a 3r
000 afghanistan
armed soldiers
only 75 000 taliban meanwhile they took
it over and they just did it yeah yeah i
mean there was no gunshots fired it's
no yeah i i just i just think the whole
thing's a disaster the whole this
nation-building idea is a disaster and
afghanistan itself has never been
a traditional country in the sense of
like a central leadership it's like it's
basically
for most of history has been run by
warlords it's like warlords that
controlled regions
here's a question joe
this is something i wonder about a lot
both on an individual level and on an on
a nation level
how much and at what point
should
say a country get involved with the
affairs
of another one it's a good question
well it's it should be probably
at a
we should have
levels of atrocity that are intolerable
right where it's like nazi germany type
levels but if that's the case why are we
not invading north korea
because north korea
talked to wyoming park or any of the
people that have escaped from from north
korea it's
essentially a form of holocaust there's
people that are in concentration camps
they've lived their whole lives there
their children will be born there
there's people that are starving to
death there's people that are
cannibalizing people it's a weird [ __ ]
up horrific situation over there yeah
and uh there's no
there's no
plan to do anything about it yeah but
yet we keep talking about doing things
in the middle east and there's a lot of
resources in the middle east that may or
may not be
a motive to being there one of them is
drugs
it's uh up until the invasion of
afghanistan i mean i'm not sure what the
number is now but afghanistan
once we invaded
i think they were the supplier of 94
of the world's opium oh i didn't know
that
oh yeah i didn't know that well the
[ __ ] united states troops were
guarding poppy fields
because these people that were there
that was their main way of making a
living and the united us troops were
guarding the poppy fields
it's [ __ ] crazy
let's let's find out what the actual
number is as of today but i believe that
i think that was the number at one point
in time that 94 of the world's opium
supply was from afghanistan specifically
wow there's also a massive supply of uh
minerals
of conflict minerals ironically in 2014
the estimated opium production was six
thousand four hundred what is an mt
uh yet in 2017 production climbed to a
new record of 9 000 mt
result of a drought these levels of
production are enough to supply most of
the world's opiate markets wow this is a
study from the brookings
brookings.edu
oh metric tons that's what it is
okay 2007 afghan opium production
climbed to what was then seen as a
staggering 8 200 metric tons
uh
interesting in 2018
climbed to a new record of uh 9 000
metric tons then falling to in 2018 6
400 metric tons massive amounts of opium
wow yeah this is what's crazy
um the the uh trafficking okay oh here
it is estimated the gross value of the
afghan opium economy including the
cultivation of poppy
processing into heroin and trafficking
up to afghan borders to be between us
4.1 billion and 6.6 billion
in 2017.
wow
it's so funny seeing those numbers there
compared to like these trillions and
trillions that they just keep
keep printing sounds like nothing i
don't even know how these numbers are
just they get to the stage where you
can't fathom i mean it's just like too
many zeros yeah it's it's also like
where's that money going like if that's
if they're making that much money
selling heroin where is it going who's
getting it
who's selling it where's it going how's
it getting out of the country are you
guys watching it watch the fields yeah
keep an eye on it i have no idea man the
world is such a weird place and always
has been i did listen to the that
podcast you did with um yami park which
was
amazing amazing by the way um yeah and
wild north korea is
it blows my mind that here in 2021 with
everything you know we're doing and
whatever that there's just one country
out there that we know
like almost nothing about it's just
blacked out totally disconnected from
the world
virtually everyone no one's met anyone
from there virtually no one's been there
even if you've been there you can only
go on like a guided tour to like one
small part of it
it amazes me that that's
a thing i always just think like how is
that
possible given how interconnected we all
are and she was saying that if it wasn't
for china's support they wouldn't be
able to survive a week yeah
they'd be go like china they need
china's support
and that's the reason china props them
up it's so weird how do you think that
um
how do you think that that will come to
an end
it might not it might go on for hundreds
of years
i think it will i think evil always evil
always falls eventually it does
eventually but what is eventually if a
human lifetime is you know if 100 years
if you're lucky there's been many evil
regimes that have lasted longer than
that so i mean many many many
generations of people are going to
suffer yeah
it's so odd
i don't know the world they can't do
anything about it thing is like they're
starving they have no access to weapons
the government has full complete control
over them and when you pass the borders
they have land mines set up so if you're
you're making a run for it you're going
to [ __ ] blow up and what's do you
know what what's china's interest with
keeping or allowing it to stay that way
is there some benefit to them that's a
good question
because i know that i know that they're
propped up by china but why would china
want
you know
why would they want it to stay like that
i don't really understand that well they
probably enjoy the fact that there's a
conflict between north and south korea
as they're both close to each other and
south korea's allies with the united
states
you know
china has their [ __ ] tentacles and so
many different things man it's wild
i've got some more numbers here for you
to help with the afghan thing it was
from wiki but they're from like from the
afghan papers i think is where a lot of
this information came from as of 2017
opium production provides about 400 000
jobs in afghanistan more than the afghan
national security forces the opium trade
spiked in 2006 after the taliban lost
control of the local warlords
93
93
of the
non-pharmaceutical grade opiates of the
world market originated in afghanistan
more land is used in afghanistan to grow
for opium than cocoa cultivation in all
of latin america wow
i did not know this i never linked
afghanistan with huge amounts of
yeah man it's in a sturgill simpson song
that's i mean we are
we're repeating what happened in the
vietnam war right in the vietnam war
that was a big part of what the vietnam
war was all about was the heroin trade
that's what's going on here man yeah
it's like it's it's got to be a factor
this idea that it's not a factor of why
we're there and that some
[ __ ] scumbag is not profiting off of
this
for sure it is there's no way they're
not i mean if these are the same people
that paid barry seals to run coke over
from south america and drop it into mina
arkansas
you don't think that they would be
making money over in afghanistan i i do
man i i believe that every every
government is corrupt
they're gonna make a documentary about
the
the poppies
they're going to have to that someone
now that we're out of afghanistan
someone's going to make a documentary
about the heroin trade and people are
going to [ __ ]
blow their wig off they're going to be
like what
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify